I'm going to show up to Can-Am, barely stretched, have a couple light beers, and just win the final.
Nah, bro, only white planes lose the final.
We asked them if they could play, but they only accepted if we traveled up or not.
Good. I would be sick that day.
You playing threes?
I want three touches. Can we play against Sahan?
No, I don't want to get beat up either.
Jose, what do you think?
Today? If they want it.
We need our opposition.
That would actually be very good training for us.
I don't know what the fuck else we'd be doing.
No, we're going to do...
Four to threes.
Boom.
Oh, RIP Fiji. What's today's date?
July 24th. RIP Fiji.
What? What happened?
He died.
RIP Chuck Mangino.
The singer?
Fiji?
Oh!
Oh, sweet darlin'.
You know that song?
What did I do to deserve you?
I know Crazy Prince. I know Iron Man.
Oh, he died too.
That's a crazy trio to be hanging out in heaven right now.
Ozzy Osbourne.
They rockin'. They're definitely fuckin' rockin' right now.
Ozzy Osbourne, Fiji, and...
Dude, Chuck Mangino.